hey everyone i'm shamlee and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn on ethereum vs bitcoin
in the previous two videos we covered
what bitcoin and ethereum are
let's proceed further and have a look at
how they both differ from each other
did you know there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide
and among them bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies
in the world by market cap also
recently ethereum as well as bitcoin
reached its all-time peak in worldwide
trading
according to decrypt.gov everyday new
companies like metoo and paypal
are coming forward to invest in bitcoin
and ethereum
on march 7 2021 metoo confirmed
that it had purchased 40 million in
bitcoin and ethereum
on the other hand people is about to
launch a scheme
where the public can purchase and sell
cryptocurrencies
initially featuring bitcoin and ethereum
via paypal digital wallet
but have you all ever wondered how they
compare based on their similarities and
differences in various aspects
well before moving any further let's
have a quick look at how bitcoin and
ethereum originated and made a benchmark
in the economic system worldwide
bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto
to resolve cyber attacks double spending
and eliminate the middleman between the
transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent
and decentralized peer-to-peer
transaction on the other hand
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin
it was first introduced in the late 2013
by vitalik buterin
after that it was very quickly and
widely adopted
because it offered a platform to build
and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other
in this economy this video will cover
individual aspects for comparing
ethereum and bitcoin's performance
in that particular field first we will
look into the introduction of ethereum
and bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language mining process
of
ethereum and bitcoin monetary policy
transaction and availability of these
two cryptocurrencies
by time bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known
cryptocurrency however ethereum with
different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but
before moving ahead let's have an
introduction to ethereum and bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference
for bitcoin it is an alternative to fiat
money or physical currency
the main function of ethereum is to
provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money
and value stored in its blockchain
network now let's get started and move
towards the first comparison
which is algorithm ethereum uses the
etas cryptographic algorithm
for mining blocks in the ethereum
network on the other hand
bitcoin uses the she-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
bitcoin network
ethers algorithm is mainly used during
the proof-of-work function
proof-of-work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate
but easy to validate and satisfy certain
network requirements
sag 256 algorithm helps bitcoin
users to protect all their sensitive
data like private keys
moving on the programming language of
ethereum
and bitcoin ethereum uses solidity
solidity is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
but in terms of programming language
bitcoin keeps it simple
bitcoin uses c plus plus as its
programming language
it is a stack based programming language
used to give bitcoin software
instructions
on how to make transactions as we have
covered the algorithm and programming
language of both cryptocurrencies
now let's take a look at the mining
process of both
mining is a process in which transaction
made are validated and added
to blockchain public ledger and blocks
and the people mining these blocks
are called miners ethereum miners mine
the unvalidated transaction
using the proof-of-work method but it
aims to switch
to proof of stake because it will make
its network
more immune to centralization energy
efficient
and stronger support for its shared
chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use
the proof-of-work method to mine
unvalidated transactions
these method is enough to function in
bitcoin network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies
but let's first understand what monetary
policy is
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting
announcing and implementing the plan of
actions taken by
the competent monetary authority to
control the money supply
and achieve goals that promote
sustainable economic growth
so italian's policy is defined by the
reward
paid out by its protocol ethereum's
monetary policies
are best described as minimum issuance
to secure the network
therefore there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
but bitcoin's monetary policy comprises
two parts
halving and block frequency halving
event is when the reward
of mining bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
the current block reward for ethereum is
two ether per block
and for bitcoin the block reward is 12.5
bitcoins
per block also every 14 seconds
a block of ethereum is generated and one
block
of bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate
monetary policies are considered to be
fixed and non-inflationary
due to this over time mining blocks will
become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it
on the other side bitcoin's transaction
speed is 5 transactions per second
and it can take up to 60 minutes or more
to confirm
either the currency of ethereum acts as
the fuel for ethereum networks
and bitcoin is only used as the value
for real-world transaction
to compete with already present
electronic cash like credit cards and
google pay it error and bitcoin require
higher productivity
to attain widespread adoption not
talking about the availability of both
cryptocurrencies
ethereum is not limited but it can
occasionally reduce due to large
network upgrades however bitcoin is
limited to 21 million coins
and as of today 18 million bitcoin is
already used
but in the end both bitcoin and ethereum
being the top
crypto currencies share a few
similarities
like both are decentralized and can be
used to have a peer-to-peer transaction
proof of work also both have a large
network of
independent nodes choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more now
let's have a demo now let's have a look
at the media outlet website coindesk
where we will see all stats related to
bitcoin and ethereum in detail
coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies
it is used to explore the news and price
data related to cryptocurrencies
and also explains how cryptocurrencies
contribute to the evolution of financial
system
worldwide now see this graph this graph
shows the change in bitcoin price
in 24 hours duration this graph shows
the gradual change in the price of
bitcoin it started from sixty four
thousand
four hundred thirty nine point two nine
dollars on april 14
at 12 pm and right now by april 15
at 6 00 am it is at 63
189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
percent
which shows the change in the price of
bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2.
the value of ethereum started at
2388.13
on april 14 at 12 p.m and the current
status
on april 15 is positive with a value
of 2442 point
with an increasing rate of 4.67 percent
down below we have a metrics table that
shows the change between the starting
and ending value of ethereum the total
supply of a cryptocurrency in 24 hours
the total number of transaction that
occurred and the average transaction fee
for all these transactions now this
graph shows
the current status of cryptocurrency in
usd dollars
we can also see its value according to
any centralized currency
like euro or inr this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies
every moment we can also access the data
of trading from
an hour to its lifetime now this is all
about
ethereum versus bitcoin we have almost
reached the end of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on
ethereum versus bitcoin
and learned something new from it if you
like this video
then please do hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates
and videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here